wir haben gestern hier in berlin nach
dem log downlight gefragt und man muss
dazu sagen jetzt in der nacht hat sich
ja viel entwickelt und nach leiht man
muss es noch einmal betone klingt das
ganze jetzt schon nicht mehr
berlin pulsiert noch denn offenbar steht
der hauptstadt ein neuer lockdown bevor
was die berliner über die neuen
maßnahmen denken bild hat sich umgehört
ich weiß nicht was lockt downlight
beinhalten soll von daher kann ich mich
dazu jetzt großartig nicht äußern
ich wäre eher für locker und ja auch
weiter reichen würde gerade weil der
light lockdown bedeutet ja eigentlich
nur dass wir natürlich zur arbeit gehen
können und überall hin ausser uns
vielleicht mit unseren engsten freunden
zu treffen
alles was man von zuhause aus machen
kann sollte man auch zuhause blog dauern
ist nicht das thema für mich
aber wenn er kommt
sind diejenigen die hier feiern
ohne abstand
diesen impfstoff gibt ob ich das ist
alles ein bisschen besser wird aber
ansonsten halte ich nicht so viel von
dem noch widersprüchlich das ganze für
dich also dass einiges open habt und das
andere nicht offen hat unser tester
können wir unter können wir nicht
besuchen wir sind in münchen hat schon
für uns nachteile die sozialen kontakte
werden wenn ihr also ich würde auch sehr
viel mehr verzichten damit die sachen
wieder runter gehen in deutschland haben
wir irgendwie ein extrem anstieg der
infektionszahlen ist natürlich schöner
wenn wir alle wieder ein bisschen mehr
freiheiten hätten zumindest innerhalb
deutschlands ein bisschen freier reisen
könnten und grundsätzlich auch unsere
schöne weihnachten haben können es
müssen maßnahmen kommen die dem kroner
spuk ein ende machen können und da
wissen wir müssen wir alle
verantwortungen noch ein fahrer nehmen
aber natürlich nicht nur in berlin haben
wir nachgefragt sondern auch sie unsere
zuschauer gefragt was sie von all dem
jetzt halten
es sollte ein einheitliches konzept
erstellt werden was bundesweit gilt
lockt uns auf gar keinen fall unsere
wirtschaft ist schon so dermaßen
geschädigt man sollte alles offen lassen
prinzipiell veranstaltungen privat
komplett verbieten und kompletter lockt
und kann sich dort schon gar nicht mehr
leisten
die wirtschaft am ende wir haben firmen
ich komme aus der gastronomie event
branche tourismusbranche tätig wir
kriegen muss sich millionen arbeitslose
aber warum hat nur trump ist jetzt
gesagt china britta viel getan
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren